fox's breaking news correspondent trace
gallagher is here with all the details
trace
laura good evening lori vandermuelin is
a teaching assistant in the loudoun
county school district she claims the
beginning of last semester a student
touched her groped her and forced his
hands onto her private parts up to 80
times in one day
she and the lead teacher erin brooks who
also says she was assaulted had multiple
meetings with school administrators and
the teachers say the school told them to
hold cardboard over their private parts
and wear an apron vandermulen declined
and instead called hr but hr they say
refused to help saying the women didn't
file a formal complaint van der millen
then asked a friend to bring it up at a
school board meeting which he did since
then she and aaron brooks say the school
has retaliated then two weeks ago both
teachers testified before a special
grand jury investigating the handling of
a different sexual assault case in
loudoun county schools that's when van
der meulen says she and brooks were told
their contracts would not be renewed and
they could no longer teach in the
district here's van der meulen going
public at last night's school board
meeting watch
i have no sexual assault victim and for
speaking out i am now being victimized
again
my termination is nothing short of
retaliation teachers are being
intimidated into silence and it's
happening on your watch
now vandermuehlen also claims before her
grand jury testimony she got great
feedback on her job performance and
after she was fired her principal told
her quoting here it didn't have to be
like this but you made choices the
superintendent has now responded quoting
again loudoun county public schools has
neither retaliated against any employee
for raising concerns about sexual
harassment nor taken any adverse action
against anyone for testifying before a
special grand jury any claim to the
contrary is simply untrue the school
district won't say more
because they claim student privacy
issues laura
trace thank you
and joining me exclusively is one of
those teachers laurie vandermeelen
uh lori given all that's happened in
loudoun county why
do they still seem to be engaged in
these brazen cover-ups
yeah i really couldn't tell you that
it makes no sense to me
i mean they have such a reputation
nationwide
and i know loudoun county really well i
don't live too far
uh amazing you know educators they're
incredible
opportunities for learning and expanding
your horizons there but now
this is what they've become
to be known as nationwide like covering
up sexual assaults whether it's by
someone who's an elementary age kid or a
teenage kid against a teenage girl
exactly
yeah it's really you know we really
can't make sense of it
what do you want louden county to do
what did you want them to do
well we wanted
assistance in our classroom with the
behavior um
we wanted
uh mandated reporting to happen
we
you know we want our jobs we want to be
there
we want to be with the kids
and you know we continued to try to
escalate things
to get that help and we lost our jobs
how many times did these uh this sexual
groping
occur
over the course of the period of time in
reference
multiple times a day 70 80 times
sometimes more
there was a meeting with
our administration with the team
to come up with some solutions
we were given a small piece of cardboard
to
hold in front of us
we were offered an apron
and those were the types of solutions
that we were offered
did you ever in a million years think
that when you went into teaching
especially something that's so
fulfilling as special ed teaching
that you'd be fighting for your job
after being
assaulted
again even by a younger student but
assaulted repeatedly and then
you're on track to lose your job
yeah exactly no i never could have
imagined that it would be like this
all we were trying to do is to help a
student that we felt was in need
and for whatever reason they didn't want
to
they didn't want to do that they didn't
want to help us with that what message
do you think this sends to
other you know aspiring teachers
in the area who are really seriously
thinking about going into education
yeah i think it sends a message that you
don't speak up
because your job will be on the on the
chopping block
lori i i'm so glad you spoke up and i'm
so glad uh that i believe you're gonna
get real justice here
and uh this can't happen again um we
wish you all the best and we'll be
staying up updated on this case lori
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else